we were trying to take tissue samples to
find out if anacondas could be used to
study how Mercury is moving through the
ecosystem and so that was really it
became can we use these animals not only
as ambassadors for wildlife because
everybody wants to see the anacondas
um but also
you know what can we learn from studying
this very very little understood apex
predator and one of the things you can
learn is how Mercury moves through
through the ecosystem which can damage
the ecosystem of all kinds of different
ways yeah it's it's brutal man the the
gold mining that's happening down there
is is it's funny because we've been
hearing a lot recently about like the
Cobalt mines in Africa and it's like
where we are in the Amazon
um we were down there with ABC News I
want to say like a year and a half ago
um with my friend Matt Gutman who's the
chief correspondent for ABC and we he
wanted to see the Amazon fires he wanted
to see some Wildlife he wanted to see
the areas that we're protecting and then
he goes I want to see
the gold mining areas
and and I'd never gotten in so deep but
we met these Russian guy you can't go
the proving they will kill you like our
lawyer's father was was assassinated for
standing up to the gold miners
there was two Russian guys though who
had a legal mining concession somehow
way out past the machine gun guarded
limit of the pumpus which is where they
do all this gold mining and we got in
there and
took footage of the desert that is
forming in what used to be the
headwaters of the Amazon rainforest and
it's like there is a massive global
scale ecological crime happening down
there that you can see from space
from this unregulated gold mining and
the cops can't go there because they
will be murdered it's completely Lawless
what's the machine gun limit exactly
it's the border of this area that they
call the pompous which is where the rain
forest has been cut and completely
destroyed and it looks like Mars it's
just sand
and inside of this area are gold miners
and we you know we tried to get in there
to film years ago and there's just a lot
of guys with machine guns who don't let
that happen and what the Russian guys
had access somehow they'd come down with
a bit of money and they had a new system
yeah and actually what was interesting
is while I was in there they're very
friendly and a really really too
friendly uh gold miners and they uh one
of them while I was there he uh you know
he kind of tapped me on the shoulder he
was like you know look at those guys he
was like those guys over there he goes I
just heard them say your name
and he goes That's not a good thing he
goes they know exactly who you are he
goes I wouldn't keep posting to
Instagram about gold mining in the
Amazon and I was like thanks for the
warning and then you know uh in June
somebody pulled up beside me on a
motorcycle and I got a more Stern
warning but they pay attention to the
flow of information because they don't
want the world to
yeah to find out oh the last thing they
want is to be shut down but the gold
miners are notorious for
you know just uh whacking people and
throwing them in a in a pile of you know
gold mining leftovers
it's really like like the Peruvian
government has to get the military to go
after them like the work we've done with
gold miners converting them into
conservationists has all been like I
mean I've seen the Peruvian Navy come
down and
literally blow up gold mining barges and
you know it's it's a war it's a war
being fought in the Amazon
so it's a it's possible to convert them
into conservationists what's that
process like or is that like uh you say
that in jest no I say that in an
absolute sincerity we we went up River
uh up the malinowski river several years
ago and I think it was 2018 and everyone
everyone was like you are going to die
like you will be shot and killed and uh
the reason we were able to do it with
relative safety was that the Gold Miner
that we were going with
was the brother-in-law of one of my
closest friends down there our
Expedition chef and one of the directors
of jungle Keepers and they said look you
can go just keep a low profile and so I
went up with a photographer and we spent
a week there and
dead animals everywhere deforestation
everywhere I mean the things we saw were
so horrible and we're living with these
gold miners that are you know they're
they're getting their gold they're
burning off the Mercury I watched a guy
smoking a cigarette burning the Mercury
off of his gold with the with the vapor
going straight into his face with his
child right there I mean
unbelievable negligence of just sanity
just and then and then towards the end
of the week the Peruvian Navy comes down
the river and everyone starts scrambling
and I was like I'm just gonna sit here
with my hands up because you know
and they didn't even stop they they
found the gold mining barge you know
they have a floating thing in the river
that just plums the bottom of the river
just sucks all the all the sediment up
and they stopped and they strapped a
bunch of explosives to this motor and
good Lord the the the sound of this
explosion and there's just hot metal
raining down all over the place and then
they just went a bunch of guys in
fatigues and they just kind of like
looked at us like peace and I sat there
with this Gold Miner and I went now what
and he went well now I got to go get a
new motor and I went why don't you just
do something else and he goes what else
is there and I went look what we do and
I sat there with my phone and I was like
see this these are pretty tourists and
we feed them food and we show them
tarantulas and macaws and they and he
looked at this and he went wow
he goes you
he goes that looks like so much fun and
I went it is so much fun I said we show
people we bring students to the Jungle
he goes to you're saying if I build you
a lodge you'll bring people I said yeah
and I came back a year later and he sat
there with a with a chainsaw a hand saw
and some nails and he cut down like 17
palm trees and he built an ecotourism
Lodge
so you give them another channel of
survival of making money and that's what
we've been doing through jungle Keepers
for loggers and for all kinds of
extractors it's just saying look what do
you make you make 15 a day destroying
the ancient trees of the Jungle what if
we paid you 35 a day to have a uniform
and a job and health insurance and
security and you just protect it and use
all of the Jungle knowledge you've
gained as a logger to protect this place
who are the loggers trying to to uh
destroy the Amazon
can you say a little bit more about it
is that as a threat to the the Amazon
rainforest a lot of them are really
close friends of mine they're they're
they're people that need to make a
living and they're jungle people who you
know the rainforest is a very
challenging especially the Amazon is a
very challenging environment so you have
these people who they have a chainsaw
they have a job opportunity they go out
and they cut the trees and a lot of
these guys grew up fishing they grew up
in the jungle they know how to do it and
so for them it's a way to like they also
love it so this is the thing these are
outdoorsmen these are guys that love the
jungle and so they you know in the 90s
we had the mahogany boom where they went
out after the mahogany and you almost
can't find a mahogany tree in the jungle
anymore
and and if you want to talk about like
carbon sequestration and the rainforest
the the ancient Hardwoods hold like 60
percent of the carbon of the whole
rainforest they have an outsized
disproportionate Mass from from that
ancient density of the wood
and so these these these loggers go out
and they cut the wood that's most
valuable and then they bring it back to
town and they sell it and then people
like us buy it and put it on our kitchen
floors yeah
and you know and so
yeah the thing is is I should you know
when I got to the Amazon it was you know
loggers are the bad guys
and if you talk to you know a lot of
like the phds that I worked with down
there were you know always very at odds
with the miners at odds with the with
the loggers and then I'd be with JJ and
JJ would sit down and he'd be like hey
let's pour a drink oh they have masato
let's all sit down like we'd all be
chilling and throwing them back with a
bunch of loggers
and and then those the opportunity
through through not vilifying these
people came to be like oh these are
these guys are great you know and then
of course out in the wild every now and
then something will happen you'll see
somebody's boat flipped over and you go
you go help them out and then that that
creates a certain type of kinship so
they're ultimately people who love
who love the same thing you love often
yeah even if they don't love it they're
people that aren't necessarily looking
to destroy it I've met lagers who have
looked at at trees they're about to cut
and gone ah this is a shame start it up
you know they're just like this is where
the paycheck comes from